[Music]
on this monday night canada's new
recommendations on the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
who won't be getting this shot plus bc's
strategy to delay the second dose
how long people will have to wait
inoculation desperation
among parents it's something to keep you
up awake at night when vaccines could
finally be available
to children no apology and no answers
we were terrorized for one hour by the
rcmp
the firefighters caught in the crossfire
of the manhunt for nova scotia's mass
murderer
and well wishes for prince philip this
is
the duke's longest hospital stay yet
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
it is the first day of march
2021 a full year since it really began
to dawn on us that covid19 was going to
change
all of our lives vaccines keep rolling
out and that is offering hope
but no community is immune to dangerous
flare-ups take prince edward island as
an example after
months of keeping cases at bay there the
province entered a snap 72-hour lockdown
today
because of a sudden sharp rise in cases
last week there were three active cases
on pei now there are 18
with no clear link to travel officials
are trying to trace
where they came from pei like other
provinces has started rolling out
vaccines to elderly residents because
they
are the most at risk but with a limited
supply
it is slow going as of today just over
3.6
percent of canadians have received at
least one vaccine dose
in the u.s by comparison about 14
percent of the population has received
at least a single dose canada's vaccine
supply is expected to get a big boost
this week with the first
shipment of the astrazeneca doses on
friday health canada approved that
vaccine for people
over the age of 18. then late today the
committee that advises health canada on
vaccines
seemed to contradict that recommending
the astrazeneca shot
not be given to people over the age of
65.
abigail beeman has been following the
vaccine rollout for us abigail
this is going to be confusing for people
what more can you tell us
well donna the new guidelines from the
national advisory committee on
immunization
cite limited information about its
effectiveness in older people
as the reason it's not recommending it
be used in people 65 and over
complicating things the very same day
public health england
released data from a real-world study
showing the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
is quote
highly effective in reducing infections
among people 70 and older
and on friday health canada also cited
real world
evidence showing this vaccine is
effective in older people
especially at preventing severe disease
and hospitalizations
but like with all nasty recommendations
it will be up to the provinces to decide
what happens
as seniors across the country start to
get their first shots
i can't wait to get back to my gym at 84
gila riviera is among those over 80 who
got their first shots at one of several
montreal area clinics that opened monday
itching for a normal life after a long
year
our sons have been terrific and they've
helped us through all of this
and now they're safe i can't wait to hug
you
so i'll wait for another 14 days and
i'll get my hug
mass interest in mass vaccinations means
some challenges
we did have a little bit of a hiccup
today with one of our computer systems
it created maybe about a 10 minute delay
but we were ready with a old school
shall we say
paper version in ontario websites and
phone lines overloaded
as more public health units began to
start vaccinations for those
80 or 85 and older all the appointments
in york region
fully booked before noon we were hours
try
and then you go the website freezes
it's a disaster while in toronto no word
on a start date
as the largest city in the country we
have
much more ground to cover ontario
is still two weeks away from launching
its province-wide booking portal with a
patchwork of plans across each local
health unit
there's no confusion some some regions
are opening up more quickly because they
started earlier they
are more advanced in the priorities and
in manitoba people
95 and over and indigenous people 75 and
over
are also eligible for the shot they'll
come back in three weeks and see me
again
while ottawa is being tight-lipped about
delivery dates for the astrazeneca
vaccine
verity pharmaceuticals tells global news
the first half a million doses will
arrive here from india
mid-week but if that vaccine isn't going
to be used on people 65 and older
it won't speed up the vaccine rollout
for canada's elderly
donna all right interesting abigail
beeman in ottawa thanks so british
colombia has decided to extend the time
between the first and second doses of
the moderna and pfizer vaccines to
four months the aim is to get one dose
into more people
sooner giving them at least some
protection it's part of phase two of the
vaccine rollout in bc focused on people
over the age of 80.
robin gill explains the plan how are you
feeling today
good this is as close to company as
shirley macdonald gets these days
a daily dose of her dutiful daughter to
make sure mom is safe
i haven't liked it one bit because
they're separated from your family and
friends
there's finally some relief for the 90
year old she's set to get the covet 19
shot in the next two weeks
i'm looking forward to being able i
think it's over a year since i've been
in a store or in
someone else's home anyone 80 years or
older will get their first shot
mid-march
the same goes for first nations people
who are over the age of 65
but there's a new approach to the coven
19 fight in bc
after consulting with the federal
immunization group and countries like
the uk
and israel that are ahead of their
vaccination schedule
bc will delay the second dose by 16
weeks
the important thing that we have learned
is that these vaccines
work they give a very high level of
protection and that protection lasts for
many months
that will push the timeline up for other
age groups
we will reach more of our population
much more quickly with the
extension of second doses and the the
other vaccines that are now getting
approved and are going to become
available
the approval of a third vaccine oxford
astrazeneca
which doesn't require special freezers
will allow the province to look at
getting some people vaccinated earlier
than expected this would include police
firefighters teachers and those who work
in processing plants
although a timeline isn't available yet
we are working on how to
which of those are most at risk from
from infections and outbreaks and we've
seen a number of outbreaks in some of
those settings
the delay of the second shot doesn't
bother shirley macdonald and she
certainly won't let her guard down until
she gets the second dose
when the rest of the family are done
it'll be even bigger relief
it'll allow her more visitors and more
freedom
especially since this is as far as she's
able to get out of her house
the driveway of her home robin gill
global news
surrey bc canada's vaccine rollout plans
include adults no vaccines have been
approved for use in children
doctors say covid19 can have a
significant impact on some children
though nowhere near the effect on older
people
those under the age of 19 represent
about 16 percent of the cases
overall in canada there have been four
deaths recorded in people under the age
of 19
here in canada some vaccine trials are
now underway
in children but it will take time as
heather urix west reports that means
any hope of reaching herd immunity will
have to wait
for the last year the lucier family has
been on an almost
total lockdown nine-year-old braden is
immunocompromised and cannot
risk contracting covet 19. 12 months
since he's been to a park
since he's been able to play with other
kids like it's
it's a lot lucier doesn't see that
changing until
every member of the family is vaccinated
but right now there are no covid19
vaccines approved for use in children
the pfizer biontech shot can be used for
teenagers as young as 16
with some exceptions allowed for
medically vulnerable kids as young as
12.
for everyone else safety trials have
only just begun
advisor in the modern those companies
are doing bridging studies in
adolescence right now
um 12 years of age and above and the
expectation is that there will be
results by
by late spring only after those trials
are
completed will the vaccine be studied on
children under the age of 11 or 12
which means it could be well into next
year before a covet 19 vaccine
is available to all when we talk about
what it takes to get to herd immunity
for this virus it's it's vaccinating
about
three quarters of the population and
it's really hard to get there without
three quarters of the population without
vaccinating children
children can get infected with covid19
and contribute to viral spread
but they are less likely to suffer from
severe illness which may lead fewer
parents
to opt for the shot there are things
that we as
doctors and scientists owe to parents
and and
first on that list i think is robust
safety data from
children and that's why the trials that
are going on now are so important
the data will help doctors combat
vaccine hesitancy among parents when
vaccines
are approved for children but in the
meantime it also means medically
vulnerable families like the lucies
will have to stay locked down and on
alert heather urex west global news
calgary manitoba released new data today
showing how covet-19
infections have disproportionately
impacted various populations
in that province between may and january
51
of people who tested positive in
manitoba identified as indigenous
black or other people of color only 35
percent of manitobans
belong to a racialized group
we know people in bypak communities are
more likely to live in
lower income neighborhoods live in
overcrowded under multi-generational
households
they're also more likely to have low
wage occupations and be employed in
higher risk
occupations the province says it will
work to introduce changes to health and
social systems to reduce
the risk in racialized communities in
the u.s johnson johnson has
now begun shipping nearly 4 million
doses of its newly authorized vaccine
canada is expected to follow suit on
approval in the coming days
that is significant because this shot
only requires one dose
it is easier to transport to remote
areas and as jackson proskow reports it
appears to stand up to some of the more
contagious
variants that are causing so much
concern
rolling off the line one shot that could
change everything
the johnson johnson vaccine needs just a
single dose
not two and unlike its rivals it does
not need ultra cold storage
epidemiologists see it as a breakthrough
that is going to be really key
to reaching those populations that are
traditionally harder to reach because
they just don't have the best access to
health care
and they're in locations that don't have
infrastructure
in clinical trials johnson johnson says
its vaccine prevented
all deaths and hospitalizations and held
up against the virus variants that have
raised so much concern
whether it was the south african variant
that we know is particularly challenging
or the p2 variant
in brazil our vaccine showed 85 percent
effectiveness in severe disease and it
kept all the patients
out of the hospital and from dying in
canada the vaccine is still pending
approval
up to 38 million doses are on order and
health canada expects to make a decision
soon there was a last piece of some
manufacturing data that we were
expecting and we received that on
on saturday so we're expecting to make a
final decision within the next couple of
weeks
timing is important in both countries as
the sharp decline in cases
seems to have stalled in the u.s the cdc
director warns of a looming fourth surge
at this level of cases with variant
spreading
we stand to completely lose the
hard-earned ground we have gained
having yet another vaccine is perhaps
the best defense but it also raises the
risk
that a skeptical public will go vaccine
shopping looking for one specific
shot public health officials caution
against that
and say that any vaccine that has been
approved is successful at its primary
goal
of keeping people alive and out of
hospital
donna okay jackson prosco in washington
thanks
toronto-based porter airlines has
delayed its return to the skies by
another
six weeks the airline now says it plans
to resume flights on may 19
instead of march 29th porter says
restrictive travel rules made an early
spring restart unrealistic
it's also warning the date may be pushed
back again if pandemic travel
restrictions
are not eased demanding answers and
accountability coming up the
firefighters who say they were
traumatized
by nova scotia rcmp plus harry and megan
on the record
about splitting from royal life
those who choose to work as firefighters
know it is risky and potentially
dangerous
and they're trained to handle that but
two firefighters in nova scotia could
never have prepared
for what happened to them without any
warning plainclothes
rcmp officers fired shots into their
fire hall
it was the middle of that manhunt for
the suspect who'd gone on a rampage
nearby
and 10 months later those firefighters
still don't have an explanation
of why they ended up in the firing line
sarah richie reports
i remember thinking when i was in there
how am i going to die
in the middle of a manhunt for a mass
shooter two rcmp
officers opened fire outside a fire hall
in lower onslow nova scotia
more than 10 months later no one has
told the men who survived
what happened i mean they put us to
hell i want to say the word that day and
i think we needed an explanation it
should have been done
months ago onslow belmont fire brigade
chief greg
muse and deputy chief darrell curry were
inside when the shots rang out at 10
21 a.m across the street a neighbor saw
an unmarked car
stop on the highway the two doors swung
open
two people ran towards the fire hall
one went in the ditch one went behind
the
garbage bin and they just
opened fire the mounties shot toward the
main entrance of the fire hall damaging
the building and a fire
truck inside the shots flew past another
rcmp officer standing next to a marked
cruiser
and an emergency management office
coordinator who was wearing a reflective
vest
it's believed the mounties mistook one
of them for the gunman
gabriel wartman was driving a mock
cruiser and wearing a police uniform and
vest
at the time he killed 22 people over 13
hours on april 18th and 19
2020. surveillance video viewed by
global news
shows the two mounties spent less than
two minutes on the property after the
shooting
and for an hour the men inside the hall
say no one told them
that the shooters were the police we
were terrorized for
one hour by the rcmp
in the middle of the worst mass shooting
in canadian history
curry and muse say the rcmp has never
apologized
the rcmp won't comment on the shooting
at the fire hall citing an ongoing
investigation by nova scotia's
independent police watchdog the serious
incident response team donna
okay sarah richie in halifax thanks
ahead myanmar's pro-democracy
protest endures in the face of the
bloodiest day yet
defiance in the face of a fierce police
crackdown in myanmar that killed 18
people on sunday
hundreds of demonstrators clashed with
security forces in the country's largest
city again today
demanding the elected government be
restored and ousted leader aung sang
made her first appearance since the coup
appearing in court via video link
two new charges against her were
announced it's not clear what punishment
they could lead to if she's convicted
her legal team says they were not able
to meet with her
sushi was initially charged with
illegally importing six walkie-talkies
and for holding a campaign rally during
covet 19.
former french president nicolas sarkozy
has been found
guilty and sentenced to prison for
corruption and influence peddling
it's only the second time in modern
french history a president has been
convicted of a crime
the 66 year old led france from 2007 to
2012 sarkozy was found guilty of trying
to get a judge to give him
confidential information on another case
against him
promising to give the man a prestigious
job in return sarkozy was sentenced to
one year in jail and
plans to appeal
prince philip switches hospitals up next
an update on his health and that
tell-all interview
with harry and megan
almost unsurvivable sounds like there
was a breaking point
that is a teaser from oprah winfrey's
conversation with harry and meghan their
first in-depth interview since the
couple moved to california
and withdrew from royal duties harry has
often said he didn't enjoy being a
prince and he's blamed the british
tabloid press for destroying his mental
health
he also blames the press for hounding
his mother princess diana and
in this interview he says he feared
history would repeat itself
i'm just really relieved and happy to be
sitting here
talking to you with my wife by my side
because i can't begin to imagine what it
must have been like for her
going through this process by herself
all those years ago
because it has been unbelievably tough
for the two of us but at least we had
each other
talking to you the prime time special
airs sunday night you can watch it right
here on global
well harry's grandfather is prince
philip he is 99 years old and he's been
in the hospital in london for two weeks
now
today he was moved to a different
hospital it specializes in cardiac care
there have been calls to postpone airing
that tell-all interview
that to do so while his grandfather's
health is so precarious is thoughtless
and selfish in prince harry
crystal comancing explains what we know
about prince philip's condition
open umbrellas on a sunny day in london
a signal something was afoot at king
edward vii hospital
it's unclear if this ambulance had
prince philip on board but buckingham
palace confirmed
he was transferred let's hope he gets to
his birthday
this is hard yeah get a telegram
telegram yeah the duke's heart might be
the reason he was brought here to st
bartholomew's hospital its heart center
is the largest
in europe specializing in cardiovascular
service
palace officials say while here he will
undergo tests for a pre-existing heart
condition
in 2011 he had a stent put in to fix a
blocked artery
i don't think he prince philip is the
sort of person who would like to have
passed away in hospital phil dampier is
a royal
expert the fact that he didn't go in
ambulance in an ambulance to windsor
castle but he went to another hospital
gives me some hope that obviously
they're still hoping that he can be
treated and that he can leave hospital
this is the longest stretch of time
prince philip has spent in hospital
last week his grandson prince william
said he was
okay that followed a visit by prince
charles which whipped up speculation on
the duke's condition
especially given kovid 19 restrictions
he's always been extremely close to
princess anne his only daughter
and if she went to visit him in hospital
i would be slightly concerned that she
was perhaps going to say goodbye
at this point prince philip is said to
be comfortable and
responding to treatment for an infection
he's expected to remain in hospital
until at least
the end of the week crystal gomanson
global news
london and that is global national for
this monday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is the sunset over horse
lake a popular ice fishing lake near 100
mile house bc
we'd love to see your part of canada
please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
bye
you